you did a very popular bit that got you
a lot of attention about a gay penguin
couple yeah it was one of the I think
was the third or fourth day I did on
this show it came on because I got to go
to a in Edinburgh Zoo I was gonna say
where I live I live in ed and run not in
the zoo we there was chicken burger I
didn't realise Edinboro Hazzard zoo
maybe they do there they do yeah yeah oh
the Scotland has a zero wildlife like
there's like two badgers and we've lost
one of them so that's not voting well
for the other badger yeah I don't know
mark time yeah yeah unless there's two
there's no third pod room outside that
tends to work my butt yeah there was two
gay penguins Edinburgh Zoo and they were
I'd read the story and it was an amazing
beautiful thing of like there was no act
they couldn't lay eggs obviously so they
found like a rock that they assumed was
their own egg and tried to raise it
themselves and the zookeepers were hard
gay penguins obviously can't reproduce
so they're raising a rock yeah they're
taking care of a rock they saw everyone
they saw all the other penguins with
their eggs and being like clearly we
missed the egg delivery right so we'll
just go find one they found a rock that
was in the shade Wow and then tried to
raise their own until the zookeepers
were heartbroken and then replaced it
and it was a very you know a farming
joke before you know a marriage equality
it was all over the sort of world right
right and then after I did on this show
I got contacted by the same people from
Edinburgh Zoo being like we loved you
telling the story was really really
beautiful there's been an update would
you like an update and I was like 100%
people love that story
they keep messaging me better anytime
there's any gay animal in the world I
get tweeted about films on the game you
are they gay animal guy yeah which not a
lot of mark cornered the market I wanted
to get but you know what I sure know
take what you're given yeah and I was
like I'd love I'd love the update they
were so excited to tell me I was like I
can add it to the joke it's gonna be
great and they were like well one of
them died and the other one turned
straight immediately
what yeah which is the opposite message
I want to say because before it was
meant to be this whole routine about see
like you know it homosexuality does
exist in 90% of animal species and you
is completely an utterly natural turns
out afterwards they can be real Dickey
about it because I'm absolutely not
suggesting that in gay marriage if one
of them dies the other ones like well
time to go back to the China